hey move nation Tom here with the
outdoor boys YouTube channel and today
we're going toe hunted the first office
- a couple things tell you why necklace
and go this water and them but I was in
marijuana ok what some white oh look at
that yours okay let's go fight some hold
on you forgot something guys what we
need our tote bucket total bucket
we love you back there we'll be back
soon alright guys get on in there go get
it yeah no good they'll put it in the
bucket now so Nathan how the bucket
works
Nathan give Tommy the bucket he's going
to put a toad in there
there he goes all right now grab your
lanterns you forgot your lantern get
inside everybody that's the big one
hold on hold on Tom hold on get him get
him come on oh here surely doesn't show
them to the camera well show them to the
camera well you got his buttons you're
showing his butt to the camera here's
girl kisses so let's face to the camera
here
hold on the still whole truck to this
day big hug it'll pull him in the bucket
anything
Tammy the bucket my wife Arielle my wife
John my wife yeah yeah let Liv Nathan
have it you give it a little basin put
it in the book holder holder
can't see it move there we go why are
you left
that's three let's look around we go
back to the car yeah alright let's go
the bucket forgot good luck it
all right so how many times do we have
four of them hi let's walk around here
and see if we can find war Nathan right
here see him right there what maybe
Nathan didn't look down look down look
right there see you see the toad hat oh
there you go buddy
yeah yah one yes here put them in the
bucket there you go nice and sit ok ok
let's go back to the car you guys are
under the car
[Applause]
wait oh there you go there you got it
there you go all right good
okay hold on I'm going to move the car
he's in the bucket and he did you get
two toad okay come over here show me
your bucket
show me your bucket I guess there's one
[Music]
don't draw amazing you got a toad here
right there put it put them right here
you'll put we'll put them right there
yeah she just be real gentle with them
oh you got a bunch you put them in it
[Applause]
[Music]
they got these little bulges behind
their eyes the soles have those those
are little poison sacs and so if a if a
animal tries to eat them these little
things excrete a poison that makes their
stomach upset make some foam at the
mouth and makes them taste nasty that's
their main different I'm gonna eat in
ding ding make my stomach crazy yeah
that make your stomach crazy in your
blue bunch energy on the pie so long
time forever yeah yeah you're touching
them it's okay just don't put them in
your mouth you got to tell their David
all right show me your toad oh you got
told hi Neil try to be gentle with
living hey what's this dunkers game all
right guys it's time to go to bed yeah
it's time to go to bed the guys out of
their way out all right Nathan come on
out Wow ya ever told you're all gone
they're going to bet they're going to
bed
well hey everyone thanks for watching we
hope you enjoyed this video we put out
new videos every week so don't forget to
close - yeah